we all know that first impressions
matter the best way for a new character
to make one hell of a first impression
is often in the form of a grand entrance
often heralded with fanfare or ominous
beats in the background these scenes
create goosebumps either from sheer
excitement or pure dread but what about
characters who we're all familiar with
already good question these main
characters have no more first
impressions to make however they do have
a lot to show such as the fruits of
labor and that's what we'll be going
through for today today i'll be taking
you on a tour through some of my
favorite main character entrances in
mostly shown in anime why they matter to
me and why i feel they're awesome
luffy facing the three admirals is the
first one of the top of my head
luffy coming in to save ace in his
execution is one of the most chilling
moments of the marineford arc to give
some context here what we have is luffy
bravely making a seemingly unthinkable
entrance crashing in front of the three
admirals some of the strongest
characters in universe so far this guy
has no fear we don't see an ounce of
quit or wavering in luffy's eyes he's
determined to get the job done and it
doesn't matter what enemies stand in his
way he's gonna save ace through hell or
high water the expressions of the
admirals and luffy say all just like the
three i found myself impressed at our
protagonist tenacity it served as the
perfect cliffhanger when he straight up
deflected and shattered alkiji's attack
business is about to pick up and with
whitebeard setting his own plan into
motion the wait for the next episode
became nothing short of agonizing weekly
watchers know the feel and we must thank
this impressive sequence of events for
that
[Music]
then we have a newcomer to the shonen
circle jiu-jitsu kaizen
[Music]
the moment i'm talking about is yuji and
todo's entrance in saving maki you know
when hanami decides to make his presence
felt and tries to make an impression at
the expense of maki and megumi then yuji
and todo dropped down from out of
nowhere starting out one of the best
fights the show gave us this scene built
up anticipation for the upcoming battle
after seeing the two fight and take each
other to the limit it's finally time for
them to take on a powerful foe together
now the writers did a great job in
building to this moment by giving the
two a good amount of time battling and
conversing you can really feel a growing
senior junior bond growing between yuji
and todo while they battled and now the
stage is set for everyone to see the
fruits of that bond the greatest bonds
are forged in battle yes but they don't
necessarily have to be done in fights to
the death as you can see some of the
strongest and most anticipated ones can
be borne out from battles filled with
respect and growth it's literally an
entrance but boy did it give me
goosebumps the way it was presented
let's turn the clock back a year or two
and go with something from fire force
[Music]
uh you probably saw this coming now
didn't you yes it's indeed shinra saving
tamaki compared to the previous moment
where yuji and todo's appearance
elicited a feeling of excitement this
one was more of vindication it really
hurt seeing the whole build up to the
scene don't you agree poor tamaki
deserve none of that and we get an
entire minute or two of her getting
stomped and broken down then it's time
for the heroic devil to make an entrance
despite his sinister smile and profile
shinra comes crashing down being the
greatest hero that our kitty needs that
stomp felt extra satisfying and shinra's
smile when delivering the beat down was
just the perfect expression for that
moment and then
time stood still and we finally saw
tamaki convey a side of her that she
never had shown before this is shinra's
knighting shining armor moment and it's
when the bond between the two of them
started developing for real the way they
did damaki's expression was so good too
before we move on let me ask you a
question have you ever felt like the
internet isn't a safe place heck let's
not even go down that route let's flat
out say that the internet is a dangerous
place fortunately you've got this video
sponsor expressvpn to save the day
thanks to expressvpn i found myself
browsing the internet without any fear
even when i've been in countries that
have heavily regulated internet you
don't need to be a tech wizard to make
this work i use it just this weekend to
watch hunter hunter which isn't
available in the uk all i had to do was
open up expressvpn and select the united
states server and boom now i can watch
hunter hunter like dozens of other anime
on netflix break region locks overcome
villains trying to get your personal
info and surf without suffering any
slowdowns in internet speed so what's
not to like no other vpn i've used comes
anywhere close to expressvpn in terms of
effectiveness ease of access and value
for money you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by following the
link below or typing in www
vinnie tube a world of safe browsing and
an internet free of limitations are at
your fingertips
naruto coming back to save konoha must
be the defining moment in the middle
portion of shippuden
[Applause]
a hero makes his heroic entrance at the
perfect time and this time it's usually
when all hope seems lost when it's well
executed it doesn't matter if you can
see it coming a mile away you will cheer
that's my experience when naruto
returned in sage mode to say that the
situation in guanoha is bleak is an
understatement after a long battle which
saw many wounded and many casualties of
pain we see the entire city leveled by
the power of pain seeing a lot of our
old favorites drop against him felt
painful and it seems there's no one that
can stop him that's when this epic
moment happens naruto now in sage mode
comes back with the toads in tow a
returning hero the last hope in the face
of certain doom it's one of the staples
of storytelling but its effectiveness is
one of the reasons why it never seems to
go out of favor and with it being naruto
of all people makes it all the more
better the same naruto that was
ostracized belittled and bullied by a
lot of the village residents that
context makes this the true combination
of his long journey filled with trials
and tribulations
with all the emotional moments and
culminations of character arcs how about
we go back to something more simple i'm
talking about black ball saving finral
now this is a quick moment but a second
or two is all you need to establish
multiple things in this case the most
important one would be the bond that the
black bull share with one another they
may have their differences but when push
comes to shove this is a squad of fire
forged brothers that will defend each
other till the end i like how this also
comes at the end of finral's defeat we
spent a long time seeing finra getting
looked down on and belittled and it
seems that the anime wanted to drive
home the point that despite his demeanor
finra's really a nobody then with his
day of reckoning about to come who else
better to come to his rescue than the
ragtag group of baddies called the black
balls looking at how serious enough
character everyone seems to be acting
you know for sure that langriss messed
up big time the look on luck's face says
it all it's an extremely tense moment
that serves to ease the tension after
having us go through the emotion of
language and finral's backstory
[Music]
as an embodiment of the cool edgy
character anukar has that role locked up
everything about him screams that 2000's
brand of awesome dark overpowered and
violent but also an amusing side to boot
the guy just radiates 2 thousands energy
but in case you find yourself getting
caught up in the awesomeness here's a
reminder that this vampire is also the
purest embodiment of evil there's no
better way to show it when he finally
releases level zero leaving a whole sea
of carnage in his wake with the visage
of level zero alukar looming over you
the only thing you can do is let go of
all hope fall into despair in the face
of the force that's about to consume you
that dear viewers is what this scene
does so hard to convey and i couldn't
have thought of a better way to do it
with him on their side why would integra
even need an army like all the other
battling forces in the show alucard
himself is enough and this entrance more
than highlights that fact he alone is a
one-man army the purest manifestation of
the horrors that lie beyond human
comprehension
finally ichigo's entrance akarakura town
yeah it's been a good streak of bleach
features in my videos obviously excited
for the final arc that's about to be
animated but before that i want to take
you back to what everyone thought was
the final arc the decide segment of the
fake garage town arc where ichigo makes
his heroic entrance now this moment it
has it all it comes off an emotional
send-off of a popular character the
scene gets backed with the hard guitar
riff remix of ichigo's theme it has
ichigo with a whole new appearance and
you just know that an ass kicking is
about to commence it captures the hype
of the final showdown against aizen
perfectly and the succeeding fight lived
up to the billing if you're in for a
satisfying reverse to the fate it's not
even close to a back and forth between
two fighters honestly eisen deserves it
though seeing eisen break down as ichigo
easily out all of his attacks felt so
good after he spent complete arcs being
the smug snake that he is there's no
better entrance to someone who's primed
to take down a god than this one
i wrap up my list i hope that you had a
great time going through some of the
most legendary hero entrances in shonen
anime although i doubt helsinkows has
shown it anyway if you've got suggestion
or feedback for the list don't hesitate
to head down to the comments section and
tell me more about it or you can drop by
at discord the link to the discord
channel is posted in the description box
and some of the links to the channel's
patreon and instagram where we can also
keep in touch hope you had a great day
here's to more lists and videos to come